[Music]
Buddha's birthday celebrated with
prayers for this pandemic to be over but
held as though it is still a threat from
the start of the outbreak South Korea's
Buddhists have closely adhered to the
government's request to scale back on
all forms of worship Buddhists
especially have been actively following
the government social distancing
guidelines as we do not want to cause
any harm to others this reflects the
philosophy of Buddhism that we care
about people it is very different to how
Buddha's birthday is normally celebrated
in the evening this was last year an
impressive parade of floats with
thousands of spectators and people
taking part this year are far more
subdued affair the centerpiece a pagoda
representing the bringing together of
people's minds to overcome a crisis some
say the virus emerged due to our failure
to coexist with the earth and there
could be more events like this in the
future but the Buddhist practice is to
train our minds to be calm and peaceful
this year Buddha's birthday coincides
with other public holidays
with many South Koreans taking the
chance to go out or go on a short
holiday
after weeks of staying put airports and
domestic flights are all busy as people
travel to local resorts it's raised
concerns about a possible resurgence of
the virus especially after reaching the
milestone of zero new cases of local
transmission but similar fears were
raised two weeks ago when millions of
South Koreans came out to vote in
national elections special precautions
were put in place to allow the vote to
happen safely and now at the end of what
would be the incubation period for new
cases that resurgence hasn't happened
Buddhist prayers here may have been
answered
Rob mcbride al jazeera seoul
[Music]